hello everyone and welcome this is
daniel
uh and i'd like to welcome you to
another video that i'm doing uh
specifically and exclusively for youtube
now this will be part of a series of
videos which i talk about various
uh instructional aspects of the rise to
chess mastery
so there will be a series of videos
where i talk about common mistakes that
beginners and intermediate players uh
make
and in today's video what i'm gonna do
is play a
15-minute chess game against someone in
the beginner slash intermediate rating
range
and i'm going to talk through my moves
very carefully and i'm going to talk
through my opponent's moves
and point out the mistakes that my
opponent is making
uh as well as the things that i'm doing
in order to well hopefully i'm gonna win
the game
in order to win the game and afterward
i'll do a quick analysis session
and extract a couple of lessons that you
can apply uh
in your own game so we're anticipating
that this is going to be a pretty
one-sided game
but what i'm going to do here is very
very carefully and in a detailed fashion
i'm going to talk about every one of my
moves
the decision-making process that's
leading me to make it
as well as how i go about identifying
mistakes
within my opponent's plane well how that
can teach us to be
a better chess player so without further
ado
i am going to seek a game in chess.com's
15 minute
plus 10 second increment pool now what
the 10 second increment means is that
every move that you execute you get
10 seconds added back to your clock and
both of us start with 15 minutes on our
clock which will give me
plenty of time to well hopefully talk
through my moves
and think about things normally on my
stream i play blitz chess which is three
minutes per game
and bullet chest which is one minute per
game or lower
playing a slower game is a new
experience for me and
here we go we're playing niyoyu 25
from belize and my opponent opens with
one e4
i am going to open with one e5 which is
my main move it's also the most popular
chess move it's the king's pawn game he
goes knight f3
well i'm going to go knight to c6 just
defending the pawn this is standard fare
and he plays this should be five which
is the
rye lopez opening also called the
spanish game and
the idea of this move is that he's
indirectly putting pressure on this pawn
on e5 now you might say well how
he has this move has nothing to do with
that pawn well it does because this
knight on c6 is defending the pawn
and well white's bishop is potentially
threatening to take that knight
so what i'm going to do is play the move
a6
and this might seem to merely bring on
my fate
because he can take on c6 and then
capture my pawn but after the game
i'll talk a little bit about why that's
not as effective as it might seem so he
drops his bishop back correctly
and in turn i will simply develop my
knight and pressure his pawn on e4 now
once again
once again i'm not really attacking this
pawn on e4
and in short the reason why is because i
haven't completed my development
when you haven't completed your
development especially your kingside
development
as you can see i haven't developed my
bishop haven't developed my king you
want to be very careful about grabbing
pawns
now it's become a moot point because
he's brought his knight out and defended
that pawn
so i'm a little bit annoyed by the
pressure that the bishop is exerting
over the night
so what i'm going to do is go b5 and and
chase his bishop away
and this will allow me to develop my
pieces uh in a harmonious fashion i'm
looking at this bishop for my fate when
you're developing a piece
a lot of beginners they just choose the
first square that comes to mind so
they'll develop the bishop here
or here and they won't realize that
every development square has its
strengths and weaknesses now what i'm
trying to do
is find the most active development
square
for every piece that i'm developing when
i'm looking at this bishop i'm asking
myself
where can it develop most actively where
can it control the most central squares
and i'm seeing that that square is
definitely c5 because
it's also contesting the weakest square
on the chessboard which is f2
that could be a precursor to a potential
attack that i could load up
with a move such as knight to g4 now i'm
anticipating my opponent will just
continue his own development by castling
this is still theory this is still very
much
common fair i've probably had this
position before in some of my blitz
games
and we'll see what mr niyoyou
comes comes to the table here with
and he does castle as anticipated now
i'm looking at this bishop on c8
and where i'd really like it to go is g4
because i'd like it to
pin the knight to the queen pins are you
know a huge asset
all things held equal i could also do
what's called a fianchetto and a fiance
is when you place one of your bishops
on what's called the long diagonal there
are two long diagonals that criss-cross
the chess board
but i'm looking at this development
square for the bishop and saying well
if i put it there it's going to be
blocked by my own knight
i want to open up the diagonal the other
diagonal for the bishop to put it on g4
still completely normal and what my
opponent could do here potentially
is play the move h3 uh in order to stop
my in order to stop my bishop from
coming out to g4 this is called
prophylaxis
which is a very intimidating sounding
term until you realize that all that it
really means
is the stopping of
what the threats posed by your opponent
that
is literally what prophylaxis means you
know a lot of chess terms can sound
intimidating
now it appears that my opponent has
unfortunately uh disconnected the game
so
he's got two minutes to reconnect um and
i
certainly hope that he does and you know
internet problems are just the reality
of of chess in the covet age
um when a lot of tournaments have moved
online and you know it's just important
to have a stable internet connection
um and i've certainly lost a lot of
games by
knocking out uh the connection to the
router with my feet
so it looks like my opponent has luckily
reconnected as he continues to ponder
his move so once again he plays d3
and he does allow my bishop to access
this very active development square now
notice how i've positioned all of my
pieces
on optimal squares this bishop sort of
lining itself up with the king this
bishop pinning the the queen
he chases my bishop away now a lot of
beginners
they have a tendency when they see a
capture to
to to go for that capture so here i can
capture the knight but that would defeat
the whole purpose
of what this bishop is doing which is
essentially immobilizing that knight on
f3 so i'm just going to drop that bishop
back to h5
he pins my own knight he liked that idea
okay so this is a very interesting
situation that's that's now arisen now
i'm annoyed by the pin and i'm sure he's
annoyed by the pin the question is who
can get rid of their pin
first well i think that that person is
going to be me i'm going to do the same
thing he did and chase his bishop away
and tempt him into taking my knight he
drops his bishop back
and here what i'm going to do is just
say goodbye to that [ __ ] i'm going to
play the move g5 attacking the bishop
the bishop has to drop back to them to
the g3 square
now you might be looking at this move g5
and saying wait wait wait wait a second
you're pushing pawns out on your king
side aren't you about to castle
short and if you castle short won't you
have a very weak king
now the answer to all of those questions
is undoubtedly yes
as my opponent plays a bit of an
enigmatic move but
after the game i'll unpack that a little
bit further and explain why
this is in fact justified in many cases
the better you become a chess
um the better you also become at
violating strategically violating
opening principles now as we can see
my opponent has just left his bishop on
h4 so i'm just gonna grab that guy
and he's also not gotten rid of the pin
so in parallel i'm going to think about
what i've gained with this capture
first i've gained a bishop and that's a
pretty big game
but i've also gained access to this
g-file and when you're thinking about
your opponent's king
want to think about avenues to access
that king avenues just mean diagonals
and files that you could occupy
arteries paths that eventually could
lead you into
an attack against the king so he's
played knight d5
first question i ask myself is he
threatening anything it might look like
he's threatening my knight
but that night is securely fast and
securely fastened
that's some airplane talk it's securely
defended by the queen
and so i can proceed with my main plan
now what is my main plan well can i
exploit the fact that my bishop
is pinning his queen i'm looking at this
knight on f3 and asking myself
can i apply pressure on that knight
because remember this knight cannot move
if this knight moves
he's going to lose his queen so what i'm
going to do is play the move knight to
d4
this has two purposes first of all i'm
attacking his queen second of all i'm
putting pressure on his knight
am i attacking his knight not really
because if i capture his knight
with either one of my pieces he's just
going to take back with the pawn
but in chess it's very important to
evaluate transformations whenever a
piece has been captured with a pawn
you want to look at the fallout and as
he takes my knight i'm going to
recapture his and the fallout is going
to be that he's
opened up that g file first of all i've
taken his bishop so now i can put my
rook on g8
and once this pawn leaves g2 well my
rook is going to have a direct avenue
toward my opponent's king and that's
basically
ladies and gentlemen is precursor to
checkmate so let's take this guy knight
takes f3 check again i'm not trying to
win his piece
i'm trying to open up an avenue toward
his king which i'm now going to
occupy with my rook this is a check
he's moved his king to h1 and now it's
time to deliver a series
of crushing blows now what form are
those crushing blows going to take well
i'm looking at this f3 pawn
the fastest way to evaluate whether or
not you can take a pawn
is by counting the number of attackers
and defenders if a pawn is being
attacked
or any piece for that matter is being
attacked more times than it is being
defended
you may take that piece or pawn in the
absence of any other extenuating or
indirect defenses
if a piece or a pawn is being protected
the same number of times that it's being
attacked
you usually cannot take that piece
because you're going to run out of
attackers that's just sort of
there is some math behind it here we
have two attackers and only one defender
so i'm taking that pawn with my bishop
this is several effects
first of all ladies and gentlemen i'm
winning that queen this is a fork
some people think that forks can only
happen with knights not true
forks can be delivered by any piece yes
even the king can deliver a fork
a fork is just a specialized way of
saying an attack against two pieces at
once it's also known as a double attack
that's the more generalized uh
expression
this and i think forks have you know a
connotation as being knight forks but
this is a bishop fork
i'm attacking his king and i'm attacking
his queen unfortunately by the rules of
chess he's got to move his king
or he's got to give up his queen for the
bishop
now it turns out that i'm not even
looking for his queen here i'm looking
for his king
and a very important thing to do is that
when you well there's this famous
expression when you see a good move look
for a better one
and you really do have to do that when
you're attacking it's very easy to get
waylaid
by the promise of taking a piece or
taking even a queen
but you need to be always asking
yourself well can i do something more
in this case can i deliver checkmate so
he has decided to take the bishop
i'm gonna take the queen with check but
again it's not about the extra queen
it's about the fact that white's king
is cornered i have the rook and the
queen in the attack and i have a
checkmate in this position
and that checkmate is to place the queen
onto g2
his king has no squares and the rook is
defending the queen that's why it was so
important for the rook on g8
so this was a short game but it was a
good one and
let me just very quickly walk through
some of the topical moments in this game
and um explain i'm gonna tell them good
game
and explain some of the rationale behind
some of the moves here that i made now
let me call up this game in a separate
window now i played e4
e5 you played the spanish game now this
was the first very instructive moment he
could have taken the knight
and he could have taken the pawn but
several centuries ago
a chess player by the name of paul
morphy many of you probably have heard
that name
one of the greatest chess players of the
19th century originally from new orleans
i believe that he was the first one to
come up with this idea to discover that
in fact
black can play the move a6 and seemingly
give up this pawn now when you're
thinking about
chess tactics and finding good moves one
thing that you always have to do
is detect undefended pieces an
undefended piece is just a piece that's
not being protected by any other pieces
or pawns
by the way when i say the word peace i'm
also including pawns are pieces
in my eye so everything that relates to
pieces also relates to pawns they're
basically one unit
so i'm looking at this knight on e5 and
this pawn on e4
and both of those are undefended which
means that if i attack both of those at
the same time
well one of them is going to have to
move probably the knight and then i'm
going to be able to take the other one
which is the pawn
so here i'd encourage you to pause the
video many of you will know this move
but those of you who don't have a great
chance to practice
some tactical vision well the move is
actually queen to d4 bringing the queen
out early but it's justified attacking
the knight attacking the pawn this is
another fork
the knight has to move back and not only
do i take the pawn back while i take it
back with interest because i'm checking
the king
and the king is going to have to make a
move either by blocking with the queen
now the king has to move out
or the king has to move from this
position to f1 now it's not a good idea
to move your king out like this in the
opening
because obviously we want castle now the
rook on h1 is hemmed in
and while this king is pretty weak so
that is the reason why
a6 is justified now bishop takes c6 is
still possible that's called the
exchange variation
but usually white doesn't follow up by
taking the pawn now the next couple of
moves were
very much justified by both sides we're
developing our pieces he castles
i go d6 to open up the diagonal he goes
d3 and follows suit
and i think that really the critical
moment well there were two
first of all he plays the bishop g5 now
he could have done the same thing that i
did to him
in playing g4 and i think that he
probably should have done that
uh because once i drop my bishop back he
can breathe a little bit easier and
perhaps now he can play bishop g5
and the funny thing that happens here is
that i can't try i can't do the same
thing because
well my pawn is being obstructed by the
bishop so he keeps the pin
for the time being now instead of this
my opponent played bishop g5 and i think
his
really his pivotal mistake the first of
two was to play bishop h4
what i think he should have done is
actually taken my knight
and then notice that this knight on c6
is undefended and this rook on a
is also guess what undefended can he
attack
both at the same time well not quite but
what he can do is play the move bishop
to d5
skewering the knight to the rook and in
this position i was planning to play
knight d4
sacrificing the rook for a very strong
attack attack i won't delve into these
complications
in this video because they're pretty
complicated i think the sacrifice would
be justified
and in future videos i will talk about
the art of sacrificing
properly so stay tuned but something
like this or maybe knight to d5 in this
position
hitting the queen would have been
something that kept a very much
reasonable position for my opponent
instead of this he dropped his bishop
back and now
if he drops his bishop back further i
have the very unpleasant move knight d4
again applying pressure on the knight
and i'm going to [ __ ] his pawn
structure on the next move
by taking that night with either the
bishop or the knight instead
my opponent made a big mistake by going
queenie to and
i don't know exactly what explained this
sometimes
you want to be very very careful
whenever you meet an unexpected move
especially if you're a beginner out
there
um just the range of chess moves that
you've seen before is limited
so a move like g5 might have caught him
off guard and that mechanism in his
brain that
is responsible for detecting threats
that might have failed so the lesson
here is that when you meet an unexpected
move
take some time slow down and try to
understand what your opponent's threat
is
and another way to pose that question is
if it were my opponent's move again
what move would he play and by framing
it that way you're often able to kind of
tell your brain
to look for the right kind of things and
once he gave up the bishop the rest is
very simple knight to t4
hitting the queen putting pressure on
the knight taking with the queen
taking here and finally realizing that
the g file has been open giving a check
had he gone to h2 by the way i would
have given him another check
driving his queen king back and then i
would have done the same thing i did
during the game taking on f3
and then checkmating him in a couple of
moves now he played king h1
i take on f3 with the bishop again i'm
not doing this in order to win the queen
although that's
kind of a nice byproduct i'm doing this
in order to deliver the final blow to
the king
check queen g2 you could have put three
queens here on all of these squares i
highlighted red four queens
and this would have still been checkmate
checkmate transcends everything in chess
so first and foremost you should be
looking for the safety looking out for
the safety of your king
and making sure that none of the moves
that you make permanently compromise
the safety of that king so this is very
very very good game
um i thank you for being a good sport
for reconnecting
i was short and i'll definitely be doing
this in the future maybe with some
higher rated opponents
but hopefully you found this little
video instructive
once again i'll be coming out in the
near future with another series of
videos on common mistakes
that beginners and intermediate players
make and i'll be basing that of course
on
my own tournament experience and i'll be
also doing
more of these youtube specific videos
where i play games
and talk them through well that's it
ladies and gentlemen i hope you found
this video instructive i would love to
hear from you in the comments below and
i'll be seeing you again
very shortly with another video thank
you